un jour et de nuit deux minutes de nuit
à midi et plusieurs dizaines de millions
de terriens les yeux rivés au ciel pas
là monsieur bonsoir nuit magique si
brève trop brève pour ceux qui étaient
dans la bande total de l'éclipsé bonheur
voile et pour ceux qui se sont retrouvés
sous les nuages mais partout cette
étrange clarté entre horreur et
crépuscule lumière irréelle qui nous
ferait presque croire aux légendes et
hopper qui ont toujours accompagné les
éclipses regard et traditions par
olivier linosa une légende raconte que
le soleil est un miroir posé par les
dieux pour protéger la terre
aujourd'hui les hommes se sont sentis un
peu orphelin la boule de feu l'espace de
quelques minutes
cette éclipse et
à
michel mandat il de la ville aux bois
chaudat les groupes terroristes
d'avancement
des millions d'êtres humains qui
communient ensemble des cornouailles au
golfe du bengale qui courent on attend
encore une
un rituel païen la fête du soleil noir
une éclipse qui balaie la terre et la
mer et l'amertume des hommes devant la
magie d'un spectacle voilée par les
nuages
un rêve s'envole les clips ce comme une
poussière d'éternité qui a brillé dans
les cieux et les yeux de l'humanité et
en dépit d'une météo maussade des
milliers de personnes s'étaient
rassemblées très tôt ce matin à fécamp
en normandie pour ne rien manquer du
spectacle fécamp qui se trouve au coeur
de la ligne de centralité de les clips
et la magie a bien eu lieu
le cercle du soleil éclipsé par la lune
était visible et certains ont profité de
cette journée astronomiques pour se
marier espère t-il sous les meilleurs
auspices reportage de romuald de bonon
rémy poissonnier et grégoire hocine
jusqu'au dernier moment seuls les nuages
avaient rendez vous avec les clips h
moins 30 minutes un ciel de plomb de fin
du monde sur la plage de galets le moral
est au plus mal
juste avant 12h18 le début de l'éclipsé
totale tous ici sont résignés
le lever de rideau n'aura pas lieu
les pellicules et tout mais
malheureusement préparé par les nuages
mais les dieux est énorme aujourd'hui
c'est sûr
soudain les nuages que l'on croit y
accrocher soudé au ciel ont tiré leur
révérence et sa majesté le soleil noir
s'est avancé plongeant les falaises de
craie dans l'obscurité la lune et le
soleil dans un corps à corps célestes
super bright a pas de mots et puis tous
les oiseaux qui sont arrivés à tokyo
de magnifiques deux minutes de grâce
deux minutes de vie en suspens et puis
la lune a détourné son regard mais sur
terre les esprits eux sont restés comme
envoûté
droit
c'est un croyant que dès 2008 après
regardez ces sept et clarté par le
soleil instantanée après lui très très
court formidable l'union du soleil et de
la lune à ces camps c'était aussi le
plus beau jour de la vie
pour caroline et patrice bien décider
tous les deux à dire oui en ce jour des
clipse 99 la bague au doigt pour les
mariés et un anneau céleste en gage de
cadeaux de mariage à paris où l'éclipsé
était presque total 99 4%
plusieurs centaines de milliers de
personnes ont aussi chausser leurs
lunettes sur les champs-elysées la tour
eiffel ou la butte montmartre 2000
policiers avaient été déployés les
services du samu et des pompiers mise en
alerte
forte heureusement tout s'est bien passé
et on a même tourné en dérision les
prévisions apocalyptiques de paco
rabanne commentaires et les nuques avec
les équipes de reporter d'image de la
rédaction la ville lumière sous
d'éblouissantes ténèbres mais
l'apocalypse annoncée par paco rabanne
n'a pas eu lieu et la station mir n'est
pas tombé et paris ne s'est pas enflammé
quelques centaines de manifestants ont
fêté les erreurs de prophétie du
couturier parrain 13 ironique apéritif
des survivants
partout ailleurs dans la capitale on a
ignoré les prédictions catastrophistes
le spectacle d'abord derniers
préparatifs dernière distribution de
lunettes mouvementée à la villette
léo et moules croiser la main cependant
chacun part alors à la recherche de la
meilleure place entre deux nuages
les spéculations vont bon train je crois
être maligne qui va venir en première
mais en fait du monde à iquique c'était
le soleil
que le spectacle commence l'astre mort
grignote lentement l'astre de feu paris
6 186 minutes durant le soleil et la
lune se disputent les monuments
ah ah
à 12h22 l'éclipsé est à son maximum
99 4% l'obscurité ne sera pas plus
intense paris s'éblouit venu j'avais
jamais vu des clipse les puisque tant qu
est ce que je suis c'est war c'est tout
cas pas de choses je peux avoir je peux
retourner c'est mon frère car chaque
seconde compte est les spectateurs de
l'équipe je savais bien la
représentation serait unique dans la
région picardie où l'on attendait avec
beaucoup d'impatience cet événement les
municipalités rappelez-vous avait même
fait des campagnes de publicité pour
attirer les touristes
et bien la météo a été moins clémente et
on fait des clips ce sont surtout les
cumulus et les nimbus que les curieux
ont pu admirer nathalie moisan et marie
pierre cassignard la folie les
astronomes d'un jour est lâché 10 heures
le train spécial de paris arrive bondi
l'an avec sa vieille ville sur la
colline devait être comme disait
l'office du tourisme l'un des plus beaux
points de vue sur les kits à peine
installé sur les remparts répétition
générale beaucoup de nuages fait
malheureusement pin gris c'est gris la
météo avait menti à défaut de voir
l'éclipsé partielle chacun s'occupe
comme il peut alors revoir les clips par
contre ils sont amers 12h26 la
température a chuté il fait 11 degrés
ils tant pis pour le soleil noir on le
regardera ce soir à la télé en attendant
la nuit en plein jour ça fait quand même
de l'effet c'est quand même
impressionnant j'ai encore les jambes
qui tremblent j'ai le coeur qui je sais
pas je suis grosse émotion de sentir 7
septembre arrivée on a l'impression que
les nuages nous tombe sur la tête
on a apporté le champagne et pour le cas
où on verrait les clips pour la célébrer
si on la rate s était bon nous consoler
et alors et comme pour narguer tout le
monde 40 minutes plus tard le soleil
réapparaît il s'était éclipsé
un peu plus à l'est ce jour sur le
chemin de l'équipe à perte dans les
ardennes un village de 317 habitants qui
accueillait aujourd'hui près de 15000
personnes
hélène vergne et philippe chasselas ont
suivi une famille très organisé il faut
dire que maman est astronome et qu'elle
a tout expliqué aux enfants
après dégagé à l'ouest derniers
préparatifs pour isabelle et sa petite
famille deux jours de route depuis lyon
et les voici enfin à perte
cet astronome de profession rêver de
l'éclipsé totale depuis des années
l'occasion était trop belle pas question
de la laisser passer
regarde pas pourquoi mince et des nuages
pourquoi oh là là on ne voit bien là où
avoir pris entre comme il étouffe un tu
vois quand ils bientôt fin
la lune l avance de plus en plus c'est
la rentrée la rentrée leur est pas
d'avancer paris paris ça va être pas
puisque par appareil verront pas plus
que ça les regarde mon temps sur cette
voie vous pouvez
l'équipe que je regarde partir voilà non
plus à traiter les clips annoncé fini
mais c'est aussi la grande émotion au
moins c'était quelque chose
l'événement attendu depuis pas mal de
temps trentaine d'années environ déjà je
suis vraiment rapide c'est fantastique
c'est magique ça a un côté magique je
sais pas pour vous mais essentielle
l'arc en ciel après l'équipe la rêverie
continue mais même pour une famille
d'astronomes il faut bien redescendre
sur terre
partout en france les associations les
municipalités les néophytes les
scientifiques ont rivalisé d'invention
pour célébrer les clips et dans la zone
où les clips n'était pas totale
notamment dans l'est de la france
on a quand même essayé de regarder le
croissant soleil au mépris parfois de
toutes les consignes de sécurité
oculaire commentaires agnès garder il y
a ceux qui aiment le danger ici à nice
les touristes ont défié les astres
nonchalamment sur la plage ils ont
chaussé sur le nez tout ce qui leur
tombait sous la main contre la
conscience un peu de sagesse des
lunettes estampillée éclipse
c'est encore ce qu'il ya de mieux penser
que ça aurait fait plus noir
mais c'est beau quand même c'est la
première que je vois l impressionnant
loin de la mer au dessus des nuages le
pic du midi dans les pyrénées
l'altitude le grand air c'est l'ivresse
avant le champagne
autre point de vue pour une éclipse
totale cette fois fériés au beau milieu
de la manche 900 passagers se sont fait
là aussi surprendre par la magie du
moment
mes talents de poudre
c'est un gardien
à quelques encablures de là le mont
saint michel des lunettes sur des
assiettes en carton il fallait y penser
en auvergne dans le puy de dôme le
brouillard a bien failli casser
l'ambiance je pense quoi qu'il arrive
vous avez vos lunettes pourtant bon on
verra bien finalement les obstinés au
furet en attendre on est montés exprès
dans le brouillard
mais le spectacle vaut le coup là mais
je continue à regarder un parce que
vraiment sinon alors un ca matin dans le
sud-ouest on a assisté à un autre
spectacle
la chute de la station mieux prédite par
paco rabanne mise en scène par les
villageois
un pied de nez aux charlatans
c'est l'aimant gersois et puis beaucoup
de monde s'est rué dans les trains vers
le nord de la france à paris la gare du
nord était littéralement prises d'assaut
quinze à vingt mille passagers près à
tous sur les quais pour trouver une
place dans les wagons et pas forcément à
6 stéphane breitner et roger mathurin
était dans la mêlée
le speaker de la gare du nord vient de
donner le départ le hall plein à craquer
se vide lentement la course aux places
assises commence sur lequel les agents
d'accueil tente vainement de remettre un
peu d'ordre
les voyageurs n'ont qu'un seul objectif
prendre l'un des derniers trains pour la
bande de totalité de l'équipe vous étiez
témoin
les gens font un peu pourquoi pas beau
ces deux journées les plus rapides sont
déjà installés les autres tente un
passage en force et vous n'êtes pas
d'ici de l'union ne pourra pas partir
avec les enfants à y aller
il fallait pas y aller un garde et
peuvent pas partir avec les gens sur les
marchepieds tard merci lui trouvera de
la place un peu plus loin mais quelques
centaines d'autres n'auront même pas
accès aux quais les forces de l'ordre
veillent impossible de passer plus de
trains restent les résignés loin d'être
en panne d'idées chez nous on la verra
pas
giresse était la destruction de paris
avec
les caravanes paraît qu'on boit un coût
réduit là bas la clé survivants
bien voir les chanceux par boire à la
santé de l'éclipsé le spectacle commence
dans moins d'une heure alors suite du
grand embouteillage sur les routes
puisque d'autres avaient choisi la
voiture provoquant de nombreux bouchons
et take a notamment sorti de paris vers
le nord et vers l'est et d'embouteillage
accentuée par l'obligation faite aux
routiers de s'arrêter entre 11h et 14h
du coup bas les aires de stationnement
étaient elles aussi saturé ce qui n'a
pas empêché ce qui s'y trouvait être
saisi par la beauté des spectacles joël
bruandet et vincent bouffartigue la
bande de totalité
ça se mérite 10h ce matin les premiers
bouchons se forment et le ciel est aussi
encombré que l'autoroute paris 10 mai
les chasseurs d'éclipsé garde quand même
le moral ou advenu de loin vale est
heureux vous avez pas peur avec le temps
de ne pas voir grand chose ça fait rien
fait une balade
et pendant toute la matinée le flou n'a
pas cessé 11 heures les gendarmes
entament une mission délicate stopper
tous les poids lourds pour une durée de
trois heures en général il ya aucun
problème
il respecte 12h20 le ciel commence à
s'obscurcir trop tard pour gagner les
sites d'observation
nous verrons donc les clips depuis cette
aire d'autoroute et le spectacle est
surprenant il a fallu vingt secondes
sony complète cintres c'est très
impressionnant
les puristes repartiront déçu de ne pas
avoir vu l'éclipsé elle-même mais
l'émotion était pourtant bien là ça fait
bizarre jeter bizarre avant et puis
voilà ça va voir tous une team facéties
du soleil ou des nuages le ciel s'est
enfin éclairci vers 14 heures pendant
les embouteillages du retour 23 éclipse
est toujours la même curiosité bernard
millet astronomes à la retraite a déjà
fait 15 fois le tour du monde pour
traquer les éclipses cette fois ils
avaient organisé une fête aujourd'hui
même en normandie
portrait avec philippe visseyrias et
frédéric faure 3 2 un premier contact
bernard millet est un peu le chef
d'orchestre de l'éclipsé
c'est lui qui le premier aperçu à la
lune en dhr le soleil
c'est lui qui a choisi l'emplacement le
château de mesnières en bray situé au
centre de la zone ii totalité au fur et
à mesure de la progression je vous
indiquerai les choses qu'ils sont
intéressantes à voir cet ancien
astronomes de l'observatoire de nice
parcourt le monde des clips son éclipse
aujourd'hui c'est sa 23e ont plaisir
c'est de pouvoir faire partager à tous
mes amis
cette chance que l'on a car dans tous
les cas en fait je vous préviens je
serai comme joue aussi ému au moment de
la totalité sachant pourtant
parfaitement bien ce qui va se passer
au fil des années autour de lui un
groupe de fidèles s'est créé et on
communique quand même depuis 73 ans nous
sommes tous la relation est entérinée
bon on va en afrique bien cette année
voici l'expérience que bernard millet
voulait tenter pendant l'éclipsé celle
de l'oeuf qui tient tout seul se
trouvent dans des conditions telles
qu'il est attiré suffisamment par
l'ensemble des deux astres pour qu'il
puisse tenir debout
il est midi 10 les hirondelles vole au
ras du sol la pénombre s'installe
regardez regardez l'ambiance
les flammes du soleil et saigner tenir
le plus longtemps possible
encore un peu on ne peut pas ne pas être
ému fortune package pas du tout pas le
moins du monde
cette 23e éclipsera pour lui aussi
inoubliables que les oncles les clips
traversé une grande partie de
l'hémisphère nord parce qu'un parcours
qui correspond à quatre heures de nuit
totale à la vitesse de 2800 km heure de
terre-neuve au golfe du bengale
plusieurs millions personnes ont pu
suivre son trajet jean-claude à la dic
nous emmène au tour du monde
un croissant de soleil rose qui se lève
sur saint pierre et miquelon
c'est l'aube de l'éclipsé du large de
terre-neuve jusqu en inde le début d'une
course de trois heures entre la lune et
le soleil
à 12h10 éclipse a déjà traversé
l'atlantique nord et arrive en
cornouailles en angleterre puis ce sera
fait qu'en sublime à 12h18
au même instant là haut dans le ciel
jean pierre haigneré à bord de la
station mir passe au dessus de la france
il ne voit pas directement les clips ce
n'est l'ombre de la lune se déplaçant
sur la terre que je le répète sur terre
la course continue il est 12h30 3
stuttgart en allemagne et dans le noir
la couronne solaire et rouge et vert
c'est la fête
cheval
les lumières scintillent sur la ville
pas des clés de ce total en italie
les astres en ont décidé autrement le
pape n'en veut pas au ciel il est 12h 56
en roumanie à bucarest
on célèbre les clips par des feux de
joie devant l'ancien palais de chaillot
ces secondes 13h28 les clips se quittent
l'europe
13h44 son passage en irak est accueillie
aux cris d'allah akbar allah est grand
dans cette région troublée du monde
l'heure est aussi aux prières à
jérusalem dans les mosquées et devant le
mur des lamentations 13h55 le soleil et
la lune s'unissent au dessus de livres
félicien direct à la télévision est
couché de lune de soleil sur ispahan 85
l'inde un moment sacré célébrée au
bengale dans les eaux du gange
14h35 le soleil et la lune se séparent
au dessus du golfe du bengale
alors y ait eu un endroit sur la zone
l'éclipsé totale ou les personnes
présentes ont dû faire un choix
déchirant regarder en l'air pour voir
les clips ont regardé au sol pour voir
les animaux
le parc animalier de sainte-croix en
moselle avait en effet organisé une
réunion scientifique sur la réaction des
loups et des ours
éric perrin et dominique bonnet du
silence d'abord du silence sur tout et
puis cette nuit qui tombe en quelques
secondes
en plein milieu de journée le soleil
noir a rendez vous avec les loups la
principale réaction de la meute consiste
à se rassembler sur un point haut en
plaçant des sentinelles autour du groupe
les façons de se mettre à l'abri mais de
quoi qu'on pense nous dans le pareil que
les animaux vont hurler à la lune est
tous assez nos propres fantasmes que
nous projetons eux c'est qu'est-ce qui
se passe ils ne peuvent pas comprendre
il se terre tout en surveillant les
alentours vous avez vu ça c'était
vraiment fabuleux comment réagissent les
animaux lors d'une éclipse totale télé
l'objet de l'étude lancée par le parc
animalier de sainte-croix en moselle
l'observation menée par des
professionnels et par le public a
commencé cinq jours avant continuera
cinq jours après mais bien sûr tout le
monde attendait les clips celle mais à
vrai dire on ne savait rien de ce qui se
passait
la nature n'est pas devenu totalement
folle mais toutes les espèces ont
cherché à se mettre à l'abri comme ses
serres fuyant rapidement vers la forêt
les ours par exemple qui sont très
joueurs chez nous parce qu'encore jeune
est sur un très grand espace ont été se
rassembler dans ce sens dans le
sous-bois et ensuite ont pris des
postures que connaissent que seuls les
plantigrades connaissent ils se sont mis
sur leurs pattes arrière à scruter a
essayé de faire fonctionner tout leur
sens pour essayer de comprendre ce qui
se passe il est encore trop tôt pour
tirer des conclusions scientifiquement
probante reste une formidable opération
de vulgarisation auprès du grand public
le temps d'une éclipse les visiteurs ont
pratiqué à la fois l'éthologie l'étude
du comportement des animaux et
l'astronomie tout changer très vite
comportement de l'animal en même temps
le paysage qui changeait c'était c'est
vraiment tout un changement global
l'histoire ne dit pas si les animaux
observant tout ces bipèdes la tête en
l'air chaud sans de curieux binocles
n'ont pas trouvé que ses hommes avaient
un air parfois un peu bête comme la lune
et nous retrouvons maintenant au palais
de la découverte jean audouze
astrophysicien je mens 2 bonsoir enfin s
qufu les scientifiques ont encore
quelque chose à apprendre les clips ou
n'est ce pas plutôt une occasion de
faire découvrir le cosmos aux néophytes
c'est plutôt le deuxième mais on a
toujours quelque chose à apprendre d'un
phénomène scène est aussi important
qu'une éclipse puisqu'un a depuis
l'antiquité ils ont été observés par
plein de gens et celle ci apparemment a
fait plaisir beaucoup de monde et l'a
fait plaisir pratiquement tous les
français même ceux comme moi qui n'ont
pas eu j'étais à noyon évidemment les
nuages les nuages a été devant le mais
on a eu la nuit complète et tous les
gens qui étaient avec moi ont participé
à cette émotion dorée surtout l'émotion
la plus ans c'était lorsque brutalement
la la clarté réapparu très très vite et
je crois que ça a été un immense moment
même si on était un peu déçu
effectivement d'avoir les nuages devant
la magnifique couronne solaire
l'éclipsé ce que c'est une façon de
connaître aussi un autre aspect du
soleil qu'on ne voit pas actuellement
bien sûr c'est la partie cachée c'est la
couronne
c'est à dire cet immense draperies fait
d'un gaz ionisé
qui est dirigé par les champs
magnétiques et à l'est de l'étude de
cette couronne qui est entreprise par
mes collègues comme serge koutchma
l'institut d'astrophysique qui lui était
en iran et bien évidemment on apprend
comment fonctionne le soleil le soleil
c'est notre étoile nourricière depuis
quatre milliards et demi d'années
c'est un ensemble extrêmement complexe
et cet ensemble complexe évidemment pour
le comprendre
eh bien il faut démonter à la fois par
les satellites comme sow mais aussi par
ses éclipses qui sont fondamentales dans
notre connaissance pour démonter de
cette espèce de mécanique très
compliquée qu'elle a le la couronne
solaire qui aimait se vend ce qu'on
appelle se séchant particulière dans
lequel non seulement la terre mais
l'ensemble des planètes sont baignés et
on continue à faire en permanence des
découvertes sur le sur le cosmos est
justement un des secteurs sur lesquels
on a encore énormément apprendre et bien
sûr et d'ailleurs les clips cette
éclipse d'aujourd'hui qui a intéressé
tout le monde ce qui pour moi est
formidable puisque ça veut dire que la
science un thé à seulement une superbe
expérience de mécanique céleste qui
disent on donne tort à tout les voyants
de toutes sortes
et bien ça c'est un passionné tout le
monde et ça démontre également si vous
voulez que en regardant en obscurcissant
ce qui est très brillant et bien on
arrive à avoir ce qui est faible et les
astronomes aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'ils
cherchent ils cherchent les objets
difficile à voir
il cherche les planètes autour d'autres
étoiles
ils cherchent des astres très lointain
des galaxies qui sont presque qu'ils
sont nés au tout début de l'âge de
l'univers
et finalement c'est cette méthode des
clipse par exemple qui est utilisé pour
essayer de déterminer la matière qui est
de notre forme rappelle matière
nucléaire mais qui serait dans désastre
très difficile à voir et on les cherche
justement par ces par ces phénomènes
déclic donc les clips c'est un archétype
qui a été vécu par tout le monde mais
qui est une méthode de travail
pour l'astronome aujourd'hui merci
beaucoup jean doses pour 712 ya ce
communicateur et c'est évidemment au
palais de la découverte rebelles
à lui vendre à découvrir ses salars
beaucoup de monde vieira en tirer les
leçons
merci beaucoup merci je me disais hier
le petit garçon de neuf ans et demi qui
avait disparue à la mi juillet a été
retrouvé mort les résultats de
l'autopsié pratiquée aujourd'hui ont
révélé que austin avait été tué d'un
coup porté à la tête
il s'agit d'un homicide volontaire et
non d'un accident
léo lamberton c'est en contrebas de ce
ravin dont la forêt du rouvergue au nord
d'alès que le corps de hocine a été
découvert mardi matin l'enfant nageait
de neuf ans et demi était caché sous
d'épaisses broussailles et sa mort
semble remonter au jour de sa
disparition il ya un mois il ne portait
plus qu'un t-shirt pendant 24 heures les
enquêteurs ont fouillé la zone à la
recherche d'un indice du short et des
sous-vêtements du petit garçon en vain
autopsie a établi que hocine est mort
suite à des coups violents portés à la
tempe droite
pour le procureur de la république
d'alès il s'agit donc d'un meurtre mais
la mauvaise conservation du corps du
petit garçon n'a pas permis pour
l'instant de savoir s'il s'agit d'un
crime à caractère sexuel des
prélèvements ont été faits des enquêtes
complémentaires des investigations
complémentaires vont être faites et les
expertises vont être faites en
laboratoire et nous aurons des résultats
complémentaires ultérieurement
pour l'instant aucune conclusion ne peut
être apportée après l'autopsié réalisée
ce matin
en fait aussi n'a été découvert à une
centaine de mètres du domicile de ses
parents et non loin du supermarché où il
était parti faire des courses le 10
juillet dernier
l'endroit avait été fouillé plusieurs
fois mais il est difficile d'accès une
donnée qui amène les enquêteurs a écarté
l'hypothèse d'un crime commis par un
touriste de passage aux états unis
l'homme qui a ouvert le feu hier à los
angeles dans une garderie d'enfants
faisant cinq blessés s'est finalement
rendu à la police but for fûtreaux déjà
condamné pour agression avait tiré 70
balles dans le hall d'un centre
communautaire juif
richard binet
il évacue sagement leur école sous la
protection des forces spéciales de la
police fédérale
quelques minutes auparavant un homme
ouvraient le feu sur leur garderie un
centre communautaire juif de la banlieue
de los angeles blessant grièvement cinq
d'entre eux
c'est un monde de dingues il s'opère un
vrai monde de fous le tireur c'est cet
homme de 37 ans connu pour ses idées
d'extrême droite à quelques centaines de
mètres du centre
les policiers ont retrouvé sa
camionnette à l'intérieur un véritable
arsenal divers armes de poing des
centaines de cartouches un gilet
pare-balles et des ouvrages
paramilitaires en fin d'après-midi le
forcené s'est finalement rendu mais si
l'amérique ne veut plus connaître de
nouveaux drames
elle devra en finir avec l'un de ses
mythes fondateurs le droit pour tout
citoyen de posséder une arme avec le
risque un jour de s'en servir
c'est la troisième fois en deux semaines
qu'une fusillade vise de très jeunes
enfants aux etats unis les américains
s'inquiètent et déjà 17 grandes villes
comme miami ou chicago se sont portés
partie civile contre les fabricants
d'armes
un peu comme l'avait fait certains états
contre les producteurs de cigarettes à
washington philippe gassot
on prétend aux états unis qu'il ya une
arme par américains y compris femmes et
enfants une frénésie stupide pour les
uns le droit de se défendre pour les
autres comme la national rifle
association et son président charlton
heston ainsi que cette famille
aux états unis il y à plus de 2 millions
de cas par an où les citoyens ont pu se
défendre contre les agressions
grâce à la possession d'une arme les
défenseurs des armes ont la loi pour eux
dans l'autre camp le discours est
diamétralement opposée posséder une arme
c'est être proche de la violence 60% des
américains ne veulent plus voir ça ne
veulent plus voir d'armes comme les
armes ne font pas une société plus sûre
c'est la population qui possèdent des
armes générer une société moins
dangereuse alors l'amérique serait le
pays le plus sûr du monde mais ça n'est
pas le cas à la maison blanche le
président essaie bien de peser de tout
son poids pour rendre les armes moins
accessible mais ici on ne touche pas la
constitution ou alors tellement
difficilement le droit et du côté du
barillet et de la guerre
premièrement la constitution des états
unis est basée sur le principe le droit
d'être d'un début tu es sacré aient un
terme et ses droits ses noix de posséder
les armes ont déjà dans le droit
américain c'est quelque chose qui est
difficile
a changé alors autour de ce droit et à
la coalition de ceux qui veut qu'on
possède les armes sans que le
gouvernement fait une interférence dire
que le problème des armes n'est pas
politique serait un mensonge
tout passe par le congrès le contrôle
des armes à feu sera au centre de la
prochaine campagne présidentielle
ce commerce représente 2 milliards de
dollars par an et 70 % des
parlementaires républicains vote dans le
sens des marchands d'armes en france
incendie qui s'était déclaré hier soir
sur les hauteurs de tournon et son meute
il maîtrise et 50 hectares de forêt ont
été détruits et 200 pompiers restent
mobilisés pour surveiller les foyers en
haute-corse à situation est plus
préoccupante en raison des rafales de
vent plusieurs incendies d'origine
suspecte se sont déclarés cette nuit et
dans la matinée aucune zone habitée
n'est pour l'instant semble-t-il renoncé
à lorient on a un peu joué hier
rencontre du troisième type puisque le
festival interceltique célébrer à sa
manière le dialogue spatiale hier soir
se produisait en effet un astronaute de
la nasa
le public a eu aussi la confirmation que
les spationautes communique de façon
très diverses
jacques devaux et gabriel camilla un
fail band irlandais en tilt dans les
rues de lorient
rien de plus naturel à l'heure du
festival interceltique
en revanche un astronaute dans la même
tenue
c'est plus surprenant sissad fil des
canadiens qu'il ya trois ans lors d'un
séjour dans l'espace
il a laissé à bord de la station mir une
guitare électrique
on ce village et coupé en deux les deux
guitares au mieux profiler ouais mais
c'est trop lent
vim
mais son empreinte
on sait
invité par le festival interceltique
chez sade ville a réuni pour l'occasion
un groupe qui reprend un répertoire de
chansons de pêcheurs de l'est canadien
chris qui joue aussi dans un groupe de
rock assouvit sa passion de la musique
jusque dans l'espace
son sens
il rend très émotionnelle dans notre
ville parce que beaucoup de choses a
très vite nous avons construit section
de la station spatiale
beaucoup de choses à faire juste une
après vote est d'avoir un chance pour
une ap de jouer ensemble la musique sous
la station dans l'espace c'était
magnifique
chris partage cette passion de la
musique avec de nombreux astronautes
ainsi le spationaute français jean loup
chrétien a emporté un orgue dans
l'espace dans l'espace pour ses valets
et ça ça va un petit peu
il ya un regroupement avec le monde
artistique pour quelques heures
les astronautes vont se produire une
nouvelle fois vendredi avec un renfort
de poids
l'astronaute cady coleman elle a
participé à la dernière mission de la
navette columbia en juillet dernier
c'est la fin de ce journal et de cette
journée particulière
un jour et de nuit et plusieurs dizaines
de millions de terriens les yeux rivés
au ciel ni magique si brève trop bref
pour ceux qui étaient dans la bande
total des clips ce bonheur voile et pour
ceux qui se sont retrouvés dans les
nuages est partout cet étrange clarté
entre oran et clips retrait puces
pullulent lumière irréelle
prochain rendez vous pour les clips en
europe en 2080 dans un instant isabelle
martinet vous présente la météo à 20h55
miracle à l'eldorado téléfilm de
philippe niang avec son 6 paires à 00h05
le dernier journal de dja vite imbert
demain à 7h50 dans les 4 vérités
françois-david recevra jacqueline
d'arménie la présidente de l'association
enfance et partage 13h le journal
laurence ostolaza antoine cormery
j'aurai le plaisir de vous retrouver
demain à 20h très bonne soirée